le hip hop est à l'honneur en ce moment
à la philharmonie à paris l'exposition
retrace quarante ans d'histoire de cette
culture urbaine au travers de ses
différentes disciplines parmi elles le
breakdance arrivé en france au début des
années 80 la break dance cette nouvelle
danse qui fait fureur auprès des jeunes
générations avec le smur faut je crois
aussi regarder ces ses voltiges et c'est
tout
[Musique]
des voltiges fraîchement débarqués des
états unis avec le graphite il dit j'ai
signé le rap le breakdance appelé aussi
ce meurtre est l'un des piliers de la
culture hip hop un mouvement festif qui
va très vite séduire les jeunes des
banlieues françaises neuf quand on a vu
les images comme ça qu'ils passent à la
télévision pour la première fois on a vu
des gens qui faisaient les trucs
absolument incompréhensive tourner sur
la tête sur les épaules sur les bras
on voit ça on comprend pas alors on
vient dans les cours pour comprendre
comment ça se passe mais à ce moment
alors que plus on partir et le virus du
break ne tardera pas à s'étendre
touchant tous les âges toutes les
classes sociales enfin à quelques
exceptions prêtre sait ce que ça veut
dire le smurf 1h trompe gold mars ea
sports sur la
la planche à voile de la planche
maintenant d'un plan nord c'est la danse
est bien plus qu'une simple danse le
break devient pour beaucoup une
philosophie de vie ce qui qui aiment la
breakdance qui aiment ce style de
musique ils ont cette musique pour
s'éclater donc ils n'ont besoin ni de
drogue ni d'alcool ni
d'aucune autre chose de ce genre pour
sortir certains ados de l'ennui ce jeune
donnait des cours de break en plein
coeur de la cité ce matin qu'il faut la
canaliser cette énergie et la transforme
en énergie positive pour qu'il grandisse
dans quelque chose de sain et qui voit
autre chose que le béton les cités des
problèmes des parents problèmes à
l'école un message véhiculé aussi par le
légendaire sydney rappeurs danseurs
animateur télé l'arrivée du hip hop en
france c'est grâce à lui ça c'est un
truc intenationale c'est un truc qui va
embraser le monde ont tu ces superbes
ailleurs parce que c'est vraiment nature
non seulement mené tout le monde j'ai
aussi formel le gros cube on du côté
masculin parce que d'abord c'est très
physique mais les fans vont s'y mettre
bientôt j'en suis très patiente quarante
ans plus tard sidney avait vu juste le
break dance fait partie aujourd'hui des
disciplines olympiques elle sera
représentée pour la première fois aux jo
de l'arrêt en 2034
[Musique]